PROFESSOR: Hello.
In this lecture, we talk about
parity and parity violation.
So we talk about a
discrete symmetry.
A little bit of history
in particle physics--
Lee and Yang in
the 1950s wondered
if there's any experiment
testing parity invariance.
There are many tests
which had to do
with a strong interaction
and the electromagnetic
interaction.
But as it turned out,
parity invariance
had never been tested
in the weak interaction.
And so Lee and Yang
were motivated in this
because it was a
puzzle at the time,
so-called tau-theta puzzle,
which turned out to be kaon
decays into various articles.
And then that puzzle,
they solved the case
with the same lifetime,
but different spin states.
And so they couldn't
quite understand this,
and were trying to
understand whether or not
one can have an
experiment to test this.
The experiments
they proposed is one
where you look at the nuclei
and observe beta decay.
So there's an electron
coming out of the beta decay.
If you are able to align
the spin of the nuclei
and put it in front
of a mirror, you
see that the physics
going to the mirror state
is not [INAUDIBLE] parity.
You see that in the mirror, the
spin is the opposite direction,
but the momentum
of the electrons,
the electrons still
come out on the bottom.
So there's clearly some
change in the physics going on
in the mirrored state.
So Madame Wu actually
took up this idea,
and immediately tested
this in the same year.
She was a Chinese-American
physicist, born in China,
and then studied in Berkeley
together with famous people
there.
Lawrence is one of them.
After the war or in the war,
she joined the Manhattan Project
and made very, very
important contribution
to the Manhattan Project
based on her thesis work.
As a fun fact, she was married
to another Chinese-American,
the grandson of
the first President
of the Republic of China.
As I said, in 1956, she
conducted the Wu experiment,
and in the following year
received the Nobel Prize
in physics for the finding.
So really briefly, we're going
to have another discussion
of the Wu experiment later on.
What she did here is she
studied cobalt 60 decay
to nickel, beta decays.
And what she was able
to do experimentally
with the magnetic field,
align the cobalt 60,
and then just count the number
of electrons coming out.
And it turns out that the
number of electrons coming out
of the bottom and the
top are not the same.
She did this by reverting
a magnetic field.
And the experimental
data is shown here.
You see as a function
of time, you just
look at counting, which
is a function of time
after injecting the
probe, and you revert.
You do the measurement by
reverting the magnetic field.
And you see very clearly
here that there's asymmetry
in the beta decays.
And that asymmetry
immediately tells you
that there has to be parity
violation in beta decays
or in weak interaction.
So she found that this specific
picture here violates parity.
And this is a dramatic signature
of the weak interaction.
And we will later see how we
can actually understand it.
Note that parity is conserved
in electromagnetic interaction
and strong interaction.
One more word on
parity inversion--
you can define a
parity operator.
And if you apply this parity
operator, for example,
on the vector, these
x, y, and z components
you simply turn the direction
over here with a minus sign.